we're just days away from the beginning
of a new decade the 2020s and as the
teens and the tens come to an end I
thought I would do a retrospective video
and as I was going through all of my
YouTube videos and thinking about what I
wanted to include it was really brought
home to me just how much all of this
that I've been doing on YouTube
represents in enlarged respect not just
my public face but probably the thing
that I've done that has had the biggest
impact other than teaching face-to-face
classes over the course of that decade
so I thought that what I would do is
talk about some of the key series and
things I've been doing with YouTube and
and maybe you know about all of them or
maybe you know some of this will be new
to you who are viewing it you'll go back
and check them out if you're interested
and I thought I'd also talk about how
the channel got started and you know
also what I've learned on the way
although I might reserve a lot of those
lessons for another video if I if I give
it more thought but we'll see how it how
those emerge when I when I get to the
end of this shooting sequence right here
so with no further ado we begin in 2011
with the critical thinking videos which
aren't even in my channel
the very first videos that I started
recording for YouTube we're not actually
in my channel and you won't find them
there
they are owned by Fayetteville State
University where I was teaching at the
time you can see the playlist of it from
their own channel there I also have it
in mine and there's the very first video
that I had uploaded back then YouTube
was in its infancy and individual users
could at first only upload 10 minutes
and then 15 minutes of video my class
sessions were 50 minutes long so we
would have me record them and then give
them to a tech person there who would
load them into Fayetteville state
university's institutional channel now I
never thought that I would be putting
any sort of content into YouTube and the
person who was really the catalyst for
getting me to do that is my at that time
fiancee now wife Andie Chaka who made a
number of different arguments with me as
I made counter arguments with her saying
things like who's ever gonna watch this
stuff I don't know if this is worth
doing I am a nobody all those sorts of
things she she was a big early adopter
believer in educational technology and
she said give it a try
can't hurt and I saw that since I was
teaching four sections of the same class
that semester it would really be helpful
for my students if they missed a class
or if they wanted to go back and review
it to be able to see what we did in the
first class of the day and that's what I
did I recorded that class session and it
was very primitive I had a flip cam at
that time there was actually a company
called flip that the the the flip cams
were associated with and I would put it
on a tripod and just plunk it down and
sometimes students would bump it the
sound quality was not particularly good
you can see too that I was shooting it
sometimes is a little bit lopsided I
would shoot it you know with just
whatever I was wearing at the time
unfortunately the lighting and
wasn't too bad and something really
interesting happened which is that as I
uploaded these videos from my own
students and then link to them they were
out there on the World Wide Web and
within days of posting videos other
people started watching them and using
them and I started getting comments as
you can read if you if you go into these
saying things like oh this is really
helpful for me because my teacher won't
explain anything or I wasn't
understanding something or this helped
me write a paper this helped me with an
exam and then other people started
saying oh you should do more of these
sorts of videos so these are the only
videos that I've done that I don't
actually have you could say full
intellectual property right access to
I'm not sure if I'll ever worry about
that down the line I'm content to leave
them in there but that was my first
experimentation with what we call
lecture capture
I started recording my own videos and
uploading them in my personal channel
with these dr. Sadler chalk and talk
videos that you're gonna see some
excerpts from right here and same sort
of deal I would just plonk a camera down
you know come in and use a classroom
that was available and just start
talking about a particular topic that I
thought people might find interesting or
that they'd ask me questions about and I
called them dr. Sadler's chalk and talks
in part to thumb my nose at the
educational experts who were telling us
at the time that lecture was dead and
chalk and talk was the old way of doing
things and we had to get away from that
towards something that would engage the
millennial learners this is mostly
boomers telling us that as it turned out
they didn't know what they were talking
about which is often the case with
educational experts they they were right
in some respect that educational
technology would make it possible for us
to do so much more and reach a much
wider audience but the idea of the
lecture being dead is totally wrong the
bad lecture you could say is as dead as
it's always been
but if you can hold a crowd and you can
talk to people in a way that they can
understand the lecture is incredibly
powerful and when I tried doing classes
that we're all active learning and no
lecture students would actually get
quite upset and say when are you going
to lecture when are you going to talk
about these sorts of things so lecturing
has been an integral part of what it is
that I do not only in the classroom but
also on YouTube and this is a way for me
to use classrooms there and at Marist
and eventually it's my own chalkboard at
home as you see to reach a much wider
audience and talk in these bite-size
snippets about things that I thought
were worth exploring
after that last spring semester in 2011
I left Fayetteville State University
actually leaving behind early tenure and
promotion and all sorts of
administrative things that I was doing
and interesting studies and I did so for
the sake of love moving up to the Hudson
Valley to be with my again at that time
fiance
Andi Shaka now wife and I started
teaching as an adjunct at Marist College
and here you see me in the classroom in
if I remember right the the main
philosophy area I'm blanking on the name
of the hall right now but I remember
that classroom so well and I taught
intro to philosophy and ethics for them
and then came to teach another class
that I'd taught previously at another
job called religion in America
eventually I started teaching online for
them as well and I recorded my lectures
again they were they were cool with that
and they did not assert intellectual
property rights over what I was doing so
I could upload my videos into YouTube
and again I started finding the same
sort of reaction which was that people
were saying this is really interesting
I'm so glad that you uploaded this and
now people were saying something else
that I found really heartening as well
which is quite a few people were saying
you know I can't afford to go to college
or I went to college a long time ago and
I miss being in the classroom and your
videos let me feel like I'm in a college
classroom with a professor who's
engaging their students so you know that
was really quite gratifying to hear so I
shot quite a few of those videos and I
think that's what started really
attracting people to my channel because
I had consistent uploads during the
semester and I started getting a lot of
requests from people to start shooting
other types of content
from about 2010 to I think about 2012
I'd been on another platform called vu
which was an experimental platform that
didn't unfortunately last the way most
of them don't in the world of technology
and it would allow people to ask you
questions and then you could do very
short up to two minute answers to them
video recording them so when they went
under they gave us all back our content
and I started stringing together these
vu shorts I'd pick 10 of them on some
particular topic and put them together
and my viewers really enjoyed that so
then I started continuing on and taking
viewers questions and answering them in
the same sort of format sometimes going
over two minutes I think the longest
that I ever did was a four minute
response in those and that was kind of
cool it was a way to engage my viewer
base and allow them to get to pose
questions for me so that was a lot of
fun to do
as I was shooting the Marist videos I
started getting more and more requests
for thinkers and texts that I wasn't
covering in my classes and so I put it
to a vote among my viewers and they
actually came up with four main thinkers
that they wanted me to tackle one was
jean-paul Sartre another one was Martin
Heidegger another one was George
Friedrich Wilhelm Hegel and then there
was Herbert Mark who'sa so I started
thinking and I said well you know I I
haven't looked at existentialist thought
for quite some time and I really used to
be into existentialism so why don't I do
a series on existentialist philosophy
and literature so that's exactly what I
did and you know I started with with
Dostoevsky and Kierkegaard and Sartre
and people like that and eventually
started covering Camus and chest off and
Heidegger Rilke and I think the very
last one that I did was on Kafka or
perhaps it was the Sartre no exit one
and I always mean to go back to that
series and start it up again I might do
that if I find myself with more time on
my hands it did prove to be very useful
for me as I began teaching online
classes elsewhere
I could supply these videos for the
students and give them a good background
and at least some of the main
existentialist thinkers that I wanted to
cover
I should add as well that these
existentialist philosophy and literature
videos are among the most viewed videos
in my channel I kind of wish they were
higher quality but that was what I was
working with at the time
in 2013 I started experimenting with
another kind of video instead of doing
these very long oftentimes hour hour and
a half lectures I started shooting
shorter videos that I called core
concept videos they would focus on one
key idea and at first I was shooting
these in the classroom recording class
sessions and then saying okay that
focused on this let's break this little
section out and then I started shooting
them just on their own and I found they
were incredibly helpful for my students
they have become the core of all of the
online classes that I teach whether in
the study with Sadler Academy or for
academic institutions I keep shooting
more and more and more of these they're
they become a major part of my
repertoire as you can see at the time
that I'm creating this video I've got
615 core concept videos from Parmenides
all the way to 20th and 21st century
thinkers
so you'll remember that a little while
earlier I was talking about people
requesting Hegel I decided to take that
seriously and in 2014 I entered on a
massive project that I didn't realize at
the time would would take me quite so
long to to bring to fruition and that
was to take Hegel's phenomenology of
spirit one of the works consider to be
most difficult in the Western
philosophical canon and to try to
explain it and I thought well can I do
the same thing I did with the
existentialism series where I do
summaries of parts of a book like I did
say with natures genealogy of morals and
I thought that's not really gonna work
with Hegel and I'd already done some
earlier lectures in the intro to
philosophy on parts of Hegel's work and
I thought I want to do something a
little bit more focused so I came up
with a half-hour Hegel series a line by
line paragraph by paragraph commentary
skipping nothing in the entire text and
I thought I'd be finished with it in
just a few years I'm still working on it
at the present with well over 200 videos
in the series but there is light at the
end of the tunnel we are now in the
600's in the 800 or so paragraph work I
came up with a new format for my videos
in this half-hour Hegel series and you
can see a little bit of it here I'm
gonna jump through it kind of quickly
first I start with this master slide
with me and Hegel side-by-side
that's a younger me and then it's this
this particular first video has been
explaining what I'm doing in the project
itself but most of them will then begin
with a slide that shows the paragraph
and then its side by side me reading
Hegel's text and then we cut again to
another slide and then we've got me in
front of the track board explaining what
that that particular paragraph of Hegel
that I've just read to the listener is
about at least in my view Hegel is a
very difficult thinker so of course many
people might have disagreements with
what I'm saying but this is the first
thing like it out there for not just
this work but really any other work
doing a very close reading line by line
by line and explaining it for the
watcher or listener
in 2014 I started partnering for the
first time with local libraries not to
give one-off talks as I'd done in the
past but to do entire series so my first
one was this glimpses into existence
eleven key existentialist writers which
I did at the Kingston library in New
York and we went through 11 different
figures that are really central to the
existentialist movement and it went
quite well it ended up gathering sort of
a critical mass of regular attendees
I was invited back and since I was doing
a lot of work on philosophical
conceptions of anger and anger
management at the time I thought it
would be cool to do a set of lectures
specifically on that you can see I began
with Greek tragedy and epic poetry and
then went into Jewish Scriptures but
then went into Plato and Aristotle and
we got as far as Thomas Aquinas before I
ended up with my wife leaving Kingston
to come here to Milwaukee otherwise we
had planned to have an entire 12 lecture
series that year
since coming back to our home state of
Wisconsin and our hometown of Milwaukee
I started doing more of these public
lectures one of the places I was invited
as the Frank Weinberg where I since 2016
have been doing a quarterly series
called philosophers in the midst of
history in which I talk about
philosophers who they're engaged with
their political background economic
background historical background and the
mark that they themselves left on
history and that's going on for another
year here and probably will be for years
to come
an even bigger project has been a
monthly series which I've missed a few
due to illnesses called worlds of
speculative fiction so for the last four
years every month I've been coming in
and we had people reading certain texts
and we talked about the narrative world
created by important fantasy science
fiction horror alternate history all
sorts of things utopian literature all
these interesting thinkers and I loved
going back and rereading many of these
writers and and again that one's
continuing on into the present as well
and I don't think we're ever going to
run out of authors to discuss
I started getting people sending me
books wanting me to review them so I
started this whole new series called
Sadler's honest book reviews I'm seeing
a little excerpt of one right now the
porch and the cross and I would you know
shoot in my studio and discuss the books
and do so in a very unvarnished way
saying what I thought was good and what
was bad and whether the book was worth
actually having for the most part I've
given pretty positive reviews I have
said recently that one of the books
wasn't worth kidding and I have been
quite critical on certain points of the
books
that's another series that I'm probably
going to continue on for the indefinite
future because I've got quite a stack of
books waiting to be reviewed
I've also been doing some live-streaming
here you see me in one of my AMAs that I
was holding fairly recently I think yeah
that one looks like it was in the
hallway no not in the hallway in the
bedroom you can see the closet behind
and what I do is I answer questions that
are put to me by my viewers in the chat
function usually those go for about an
hour and a half there are a lot of fun
and I also do pop-ups when I have the
time
all of those are under written by my
patreon supporters when I reached a
certain level of patreon support I
pledged that I would start doing these
AMA and pop-up sessions and I've been
pretty good about getting them in each
month here there you see me like showing
the bookshelf off so you get the idea of
what those are like
in 2018 I started another series called
ideas that matter in which I would have
sit-down conversations with people who I
thought had something really interesting
to say and contribute to very often
these are people who I I know and I have
you could say some chemistry with and we
get into some great discussions often
veering off topic and coming back on you
see Sheila Payton here one of our great
Milwaukee local authors and and she's
involved in the community quite a bit I
got to know her through the writing
group that were both involved in and
then here's another one with Chris Gill
that I shot when I was in London for
stoical on 2018 and we had a great
conversation about his forthcoming book
about stoicism and virtue ethics and I'm
going to start doing more of these as
the new millennium the new decade
approaches and I'm really looking
forward to having more of these
conversations and chats with all these
very interesting people
another series that I actually started
this year is advice for lifelong
learners and people engaged in
self-directed study about how to
approach particular thinkers or
movements in philosophy so far I've
mostly done just things in ancient and a
little bit of medieval but I intend to
roll these out and expand it to include
all sorts of thinkers across the wide
spectrum of approaches and throughout
the timeline of history and hopefully
these will be useful for people I think
I'll be rolling out some adjunct videos
as well about how to successfully
approach philosophical texts I did one
like that years and years ago for my
students which really needs to be
updated but that's one of the main
series that I'm working on now I try to
roll out one of those each month
so there that's quite a lot of YouTube
content over the course of this decade
and I have no plans to quit anytime soon
I'm hoping that YouTube is gonna stay
around its present format who knows what
technology is gonna look like ten years
from now think about the radical
transformations that we've had just in
the course of this decade and how many
new features have been rolled out so who
knows what's gonna happen I can tell you
this I'm gonna keep on doing the talk
series and uploading core concept videos
and half hour hagel videos and doing
interviews and book reviews and AMAs and
all these sorts of things and I'll
probably have some other things lined up
as well as new ideas occur to me so you
know if any of this stuff interests you
can always go back and find most of this
I think in playlist devoted specifically
to it if you've missed out on some of
the things that you might want to check
up on and you know if you've got ideas
for what you'd like to see most of the
time I'm not looking for advice from
people but if you want to leave them as
comments on this and you know dream big
I'll do my my unusual thing which is to
say yeah that sounds pretty good can't
say that I'll actually take on all those
ideas because probably I won't have you
know the available time even if you know
patreon radically boosts up and I all I
can do is spend time doing YouTube
videos the amount of stuff that people
ask for from you can't possibly be met
by one content producer but I can get
quite a bit done I will say a few other
things before I close this I'm fortunate
in that I've got a base of viewers and
subscribers who really do like the
content that I am producing and share it
with other people and and help support
the the channel and the work that I'm
doing many of the comments that
it are quite encouraging many of the
comments that I get like I put are also
quite heartening in that people are
saying this is really helpful for me for
the classes I'm taking for my own
lifelong learning in order to help me
get through this paper this this test
with this professor who won't explain
anything so that's all quite gratifying
I really enjoy the interactions that I
have with with viewers and subscribers
through the AMAs and in discussions of
content I've gotten to be friends with
quite a few of them over these last 10
years or so of YouTube content so a lot
of good things coming up you know
hopefully remain healthy and keep
churning out the content on my
chalkboard back here so you know what
we'll see what happens in this next
decade I hope it's a healthy and
prosperous one for you on your end and
that you have a great new year
you